« Encore un abruti sur YouTube qui ne sait pas quoi faire de son chômage »
« Tes vidéos sont vraiment à chier... pas étonnant de la part d'une merde comme toi »
C'est bien, il y a une forme de logique
« Nul, tu racontes de la merde [BIP] »
Là le problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas...
C'est fort de, de puissance
« Déjà qu'à... Déjà qu'à... j'en peux plus que tu [BIP]... »
« ...de tout le monde sur YouTube, c'est pas pour aller te voir en spectacle ! »
Est-ce qu'on peut venir en spectacle pour dire à la fin "Et en plus..." Non ?
« Espèce d'abruti, on sait que c'est des complices, tu crois qu'on est aussi cons que toi ? »
Merci Loïc d'avoir fait cette petite sélection des commentaires sur la chaîne...
Tu as utilisé combien de vidéos pour faire cette sélection-là du coup ?
(Cette sélection-là ?)
Ouais
(Une seule)
Vidéo ?
(Une seule vidéo)
D'accord. Après j'imagine que ça t'a pris du temps quand même, donc merci
(Non non, pas de temps... genre 2 minutes)
Moi je vais prendre un peu plus de temps pour encaisser ça. Si ça dérange personne
Salut ! Pas évident de calmer son mental, de l'empêcher faire des projections, de gérer ses émotions
ou tout simplement de faire un petit peu le vide pour empêcher notre cerveau de nous imposer ses propres pensées.
Aujourd'hui on va parler de zéro mental mais je vais vous donner quelques astuces pour
empêcher votre mental de prendre le contrôle et des décisions à votre place.
Loïc, générique !
La vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisée par l'application Petit Bambou
C'est une application très utile que vous allez pouvoir utiliser, je vous en reparlerai à la fin de la vidéo.
Depuis quelques années le cerveau est devenu un petit peu le roi : il passionne, il attire les gens
et je suis vraiment bien placé pour le savoir.
Mais ce dont nous avons peu parlé quand même ces 3 dernières années sur la chaîne
c'est que le cerveau ne doit pas devenir un roi tyrannique, il ne doit pas être omnipotent.
Personnellement j'ai compris ça malgré moi il y'a plus d'une dizaine d'années et je suis sûr que vous aussi
vous avez vécu ces moments
où on est saoulé que notre cerveau tourne à plein régime et nous envoie des pensées qu'on n'a pas forcément décidées
Alors là Loïc, il y aura le premier panneau, "Panneau 1" et dessus il y a marqué "Pourquoi calmer le mental ?"
Et... tu peux faire copier-coller.
Pourquoi reprendre le contrôle du mental ?
Pour reprendre simplement le contrôle sur vos émotions
sur vos pensées et sur vos décisions.
Quand vos pensées s'organisent malgré vous, complètement inconsciemment
alors elles sont remplies de biais qui vous sont personnels.
Vos raisonnements sont complètement trafiqués et vous ressentez alors des émotions négatives
que vous n'aviez pas décidées en amont !
« Qu'est ce que c'est ce bordel ?! »
Voilà : ça, c'est négatif.
Vous subissez alors complètement votre activité mentale
qui demande tout le temps à être le centre du monde.
Voici 5 astuces que j'utilise depuis plus de dix ans pour reprendre le contrôle.
Attends, il y a la 1, la 2, la 3...
...la 4 c'est celle-ci ...et la 5. Voilà c'est ça, 5 !
La première astuce est de se reconnecter à l'instant présent, j'en avais parlé en 2016 sur la chaîne.
C'est très important et en même temps ça paraît évident quand on le dit, mais le faites-vous vraiment ?
Est-ce que ça ne vous arrive pas de marcher dans la rue
d'être dans le flux de vos pensées
et de ne pas avoir décidé de ce que vous êtes en train de penser ?
Vous le vivez un petit peu comme un rêve...
« C'est vrai que ça fait plaisir d'aller manger chez Thomas ce soir, mais après je viens les mains vides... »
« Bon bah j'ai rien ramené, j'ai rien ramené ! Et puis en même temps il ne va pas faire la gueule quoi ! »
« À un moment donné tu n'invites pas les gens en espérant qu'ils amènent quelque chose ! »
« S'il me fait une réflexion je vais lui dire qu'il est relou, il est toujours dans le jugement ! »
Oui ! Exactement ce genre de moments où on a tout un fil de pensée qui se déroule
on ne l'a pas forcément décidé, on ne sait pas pourquoi il est forcément négatif comme ça
et vous avez une conclusion qui est complètement erronée.
Ça c'est quand vous n'êtes pas dans l'instant présent, vous subissez le mental.
L'objectif est donc de vous ramener ici et maintenant.
Pour faire ça il n'y a pas trente mille solutions, il faut dézoomer...
C'est-à-dire complètement l'inverse de ça Loïc.
...pour pouvoir prendre du recul et que tout devienne un peu plus net.
Pour vous reconnecter au présent c'est très simple, posez-vous juste la question de temps en temps :
Pourquoi je suis en train de penser à ça ? Attends je me calme.
Est-ce que j'ai vraiment décidé de penser à ça ? Qu'est ce que j'en pense vraiment si je l'analyse ?
Où suis-je maintenant ? Où vais-je ?
Vous coupez toutes les projections
futures des pensées sur le futur.
Si vous étiez au contraire en train de penser au passé
vous coupez aussi tous les trucs de nostalgie ou de remords ou de regrets.
Juste, vous observez un peu où vous êtes, vous observez vos émotions actuelles
et vous observez à quoi vous pensiez et vous vérifiez si vous aviez décidé ça.
En général non !
Le simple fait de prendre ce recul-là permet de vous remettre dans le présent.
Merci Jamy !
Ce que vous pouvez faire également, qui va vraiment vous aider à vous maintenir dans l'instant présent
c'est le soir quand vous vous couchez, simplement vous faites le film de votre journée
mais tranche par tranche, morceau de la journée par morceau de la journée.
vous vous remémorez ce qui s'est passé, vous observez un peu ça
vous observez ce que vous pensiez, ce que vous avez retenu de tout ça.
Et vous vous refaites vraiment toute la journée. Ça va ancrer cette journée dans le présent
et ça va vous éviter de vivre les journées en mode flèche sans les voir passer.
L'instant présent !
Il y a un best-seller qui existe qui s'appelle "L'instant présent" d'Eckhart Tolle.
Je vous recommande vivement ce livre, je mettrai un petit lien dans la description.
Astuce numéro 2 : les prises de décision.
Alors là c'est pas vraiment une astuce c'est surtout l'importance de calmer le mental.
Quand votre mental est saturé par d'autres informations
soit que vous n'avez pas décidées, soit des émotions un peu négatives, soit des projections du passé
alors il n'est plus capable de faire une décision pure, vraiment factuelle et raisonnée.
Le raisonnement n'est pas stable et c'est pourquoi il faut un peu purifier tout ce qu'il y a là-haut
pour pouvoir observer les choses dans leur globalité et faire les bons choix.
L'exemple très simple, c'est que si vous devez faire des calculs un peu complexes sur un grand tableau d'école
vous allez forcément nettoyer le tableau avant pour le rendre bien neutre et faire vos calculs.
Là, imaginez que le tableau soit déjà plein plein de choses et que vous deviez faire des calculs :
ce serait la galère !
Oui, cette métaphore vous est offerte par Fabien Olicard.
Une astuce néanmoins pour la prise de décision, c'est lorsque vous devez faire un choix.
Si jamais vous avez peur d'être parasité par l'émotionnel
par exemple vous avez un choix entre deux travails
vous connaissez bien les personnes et vous savez pas trop vers quel travail pencher
bref tous les choix dont vous n'êtes pas sûr d'avoir la maîtrise émotionnelle ou cérébrale.
Dans un tableau vous mettez tous les avantages du premier choix et tous les avantages du second choix.
Dans un second tableau tous les désavantages du premier choix et tous les désavantages du deuxième choix.
Et vous vous décentrez pour regarder tout ça de manière factuelle et vous
allez pouvoir faire une prise de décision comme si c'était le choix pour quelqu'un d'autre.
Vous auriez sûrement fait ça si vous n'étiez pas impliqué personnellement, vous auriez regardé les points un par un
C'est ce que vous faites quand vous remettez ça sous forme de tableau.
N'hésitez pas à le faire, ça aide beaucoup.
Astuce 3 : la méditation.
Évidemment je ne parle pas forcément d'ASMR
néanmoins on n'a rien trouvé de mieux pour calmer le mental que la méditation.
C'est l'activité la plus saine pour faire un nettoyage de l'esprit
et ça doit être fait de manière quotidienne.
Sauf qu'on n'a jamais le temps pour le faire.
On n'a jamais le temps pour le faire parce que on n'est pas assez dans l'instant présent.
Alors justement on va parler un petit peu de l'importance de méditer.
Le but de la méditation c'est de couper l'espèce de pilote automatique qu'il y a là-haut.
Donc on va aider le mental a retrouver de la sérénité.
Mais quand on dit ça à quelqu'un qui n'a jamais médité il fait "je commence par quoi ?"
Et à chaque fois les réponses sont très douteuses.
Même moi quand j'essaye d'expliquer à quelqu'un comment il pourrait faire pour méditer
je sais pas bien répondre à ses questions. Les questions c'est :
« Je dois penser à quoi ? »
À rien précisément... le but c'est de faire le vide.
« Oui mais on ne peut pas penser à rien »
Alors oui c'est vrai...
En fait il y a quelque chose de très simple à faire :
quand vous méditez, vous mettez un petit peu dans un état de relaxation
et puis quand une pensée apparaît, c'est un petit peu comme un nuage dans le ciel
vous devez observer cette pensée, l'analyser un petit peu
ne pas la juger en fait, ne pas vous dire "pourquoi je pense à ça", etc.
C'est juste ce qui est apparu spontanément et vous essayer de la faire passer
comme si vous souffliez sur le nuage.
C'est très facile de trouver des images pour faire ça.
C'est beaucoup plus compliqué de le faire au tout départ, c'est normal
mais il y a des solutions pour ça, on va y revenir.
L'un des buts ultimes de la méditation, c'est d'atteindre la pleine conscience.
Donc pour commencer avant même d'essayer de méditer
vérifiez que vous êtes dans une pièce où vous ne serez pas dérangé
vous coupez votre téléphone, vous coupez toute distraction possible
si vous avez faim, mangez avant
ne faites pas ça quand vous êtes trop fatigué
parce que l'idée n'est pas de s'endormir non plus en méditant.
Ça doit être un instant de repos à vous, rien qu'à vous
dans quelque chose, une situation on va dire, au global confortable.
La solution la plus simple pour y arriver quand on est ultra débutant, débutant ou comme moi confirmé
ça reste la méditation guidée.
Alors ce n'est pas de l'hypnose, ça pourrait ressembler un petit peu à l'hypnose conversationnelle
mais ce n'est pas ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose de serein où il y a quelqu'un qui va guider notre processus
qui va nous donner des étapes.
On va être aussi soutenu en général par une musique
et surtout il va nous emmener sans qu'on ait à se soucier du temps
ou de ce que je fais maintenant
ce que je dois faire dans cet état-là...
C'est la base de la méditation guidée et c'est exactement ce que fait l'application Petit Bambou
qui je vous l'avais dit, sponsorise cette vidéo.
Personnellement je l'utilise depuis quasiment sa création il y a 5 ans
je n'ai jamais arrêté de l'utiliser depuis
parce qu'elles offre des avantages certains.
Déjà c'est une application, donc j'ai mes statistiques.
Donc ça j'aime bien quand j'ai mes statistiques sur quelque chose. On ne va pas se mentir, je suis un peu geek.
Elle est extrêmement quali, tant dans la forme que dans le fond.
Les méditations font en moyenne une dizaine de minutes surtout dans les premières.
C'est très bien parce qu'on n'a pas forcément tous une heure dans la journée pour faire de la méditation.
Mais, je le crois et je ne suis pas seul à le croire :
il vaut mieux méditer un petit peu tous les jours qu'une fois de temps en temps
surtout quand le "temps en temps" va s'espacer de plus en plus pour devenir jamais.
Dans l'application Petit Bambou, vous allez trouver les méditations guidées qui font en moyenne 10 minutes.
Les 8 premières sont offertes donc n'hésitez pas à essayer pour voir ce que c'est directement
et puis les 8 premières c'est vraiment en mode découverte donc si vous n'avez jamais médité de votre vie ça va être très cool.
Pour ceux qui veulent continuer ou avoir d'autres méditations il y a des systèmes
d'abonnements qui sont mensuels ou annuels. Je crois que ça commence à partir de 4,99€ par mois il me semble.
Rectification ici si ce n'est pas ça.
Autre chose qui je pense va vous intéresser : les auteurs et les voix de Petit Bambou
donc des méditations guidées
sont des experts dans leurs domaines respectifs.
Vous pouvez aller sur le site de Petit Bambou
il y a un endroit où vous avez la liste de tout le monde : vous voyez leur visage,  vous voyez leur nom
et surtout vous voyez leur CV et quelles sont les méditations qu'ils ont créées dans l'application.
Ça c'est cool, c'est pas un truc qui a été fait avec les pieds n'importe comment, ça a été fait avec les têtes...
...et avec le cœur.
(Eh Fabien ?)
Oui !
(Quand est-ce que je médite moi ?)
Excellente question improvisée !
Quand est-ce qu'on organise sa routine de méditation ?
Forcément au début un petit peu comme à chaque fois qu'on veut créer une nouvelle habitude dans sa vie
on est très motivé et donc peu importe le moment.
Mais avec le temps ça va être dur de maintenir cette habitude parce que dès qu'on la rate une fois
on la rate deux fois et puis après on ne reprend pas.
Il faut en moyenne 66 jours pour qu'une nouvelle routine devienne une habitude spontanée.
Personnellement je fais ma méditation le matin, quasiment après le réveil.
Je vous conseille ce moment-là, principalement parce que vous n'allez pas être parasité par quoi que ce soit
à la condition sine qua non...
Sinéquanone, si tu me regardes !
...que vous n'ayez pas encore mis le nez dans votre portable.
Voici comment je vous propose d'organiser votre routine :
si vous avez laissé votre téléphone allumé durant la nuit
vous vous réveillez vous le mettez en mode avion, vous ne mettez pas le nez dedans
vous vous faites si vous voulez votre petit déjeuner avant pour ceux qui ont faim
vous pouvez aller à la salle de bains, personnellement je préfère méditer quand je me suis lavé, d'autres préfèrent le faire avant
je vous recommande de faire ça, comme ça vous êtes débarrassés des tâches du matin
et vous vous mettez ensuite à faire votre méditation avec l'application Petit Bambou.
Une fois, et seulement une fois que vous aurez fait la méditation
vous pourrez réellement allumer votre téléphone
et commencer à regarder vos notifications et tout ce que vous voulez.
Mais si vous mettez ça plus tard dans votre journée, vous allez toujours être un peu parasité
avec ce que vous avez encore à faire dans la journée, ce qui s'est rajouté, etc.
Ça va être plus compliqué de trouver le moment de méditer.
Après il y en a qui préfèrent le faire le soir en rentrant chez eux ou avant de se coucher.
J'ai juste peur qu'en faisant ça, quand je rentre fatigué, j'ai – c'est très étrange à dire – la flemme de méditer.
Alors que ce n'est que consacrer 10 minutes à moi-même dans la journée.
Personnellement je me méfie de moi-même pour faire ça, donc je le fais le matin
c'est pour ça que je vous recommande le matin
mais surtout trouvez votre propre rythme c'est ça qui est important.
L'application Petit Bambou est disponible sur l'iPhone, elle est disponible sur Android.
Évidemment vous avez le lien dans la description. Il n'y a pas de code particulier mais je vous l'ai dit :
les 8 premières méditations guidées vous sont offertes donc essayez-le, comme ça vous verrez.
Astuce numéro 4-5 : c'est l'observation de ses émotions.
J'ai dit 4-5 Loïc ?
(Oui)
C'est parce que je ne sais plus trop comment j'avais organisé les astuces.
Mais j'observe mes émotions et je vois que ça ne me dérange pas.
On parle souvent du non verbal sur la chaîne, mais à quel moment on observe le nôtre ?
À quel moment s'observe nous-mêmes et on analyse nos propres micro-expressions, quasiment, mais en tout cas nos propres émotions ?
La réponse : jamais.
Pourquoi je dis "jamais" comme un mec bourré ? Parce que je pensais à la Cité de la peur :
« Et Odile Deray. Jamais ! »
Like si tu as la référence.
Quand vous ressentez une émotion qui est autre que la joie
parce que la joie on ne s'en plaint pas trop quand même
prenez le temps de l'analyser avant de la subir.
Les émotions on les subit, elles montent et on fait avec.
Néanmoins on peut se décentrer juste pour se poser quelques questions simples :
Pourquoi je ressens ça ? Qu'est ce que ça me fait ? Est-ce que c'est logique je ressente ça ou pas ?
Et ensuite laissez la vivre et ne vous jugez pas.
N'allez pas contre. Le problème d'aller contre ses émotions
c'est qu'on ne peut pas les switcher après
alors que si vous prenez le temps de l'analyser, vous pouvez aussi décider de passer dans autre émotion plus positive.
Par exemple avec la fatigue, avec le rythme que j'ai, parfois ça m'arrive
de ne pas avoir envie de faire quelque chose ou d'être simplement de mauvaise humeur.
Sauf qu'avant de faire cette chose, si je dois absolument la faire, je vais prendre le temps de m'analyser
je vais me moquer de moi, je vais me foutre de ma gueule mentalement
et je vais prendre le temps de switcher d'émotion et d'être content simplement de faire ce que je fais
de me rappeler pourquoi en fait c'est cool et pourquoi tout va bien dans ma vie
et que c'est pas grave que j'aie eu une émotion négative, je ne me juge pas là-dessus
ça arrive à tout le monde, c'est normal, c'est logique, mais maintenant il est temps de passer à autre chose.
Juste rationaliser ça en prenant un peu de recul
ça permet vraiment de décider si on est quelqu'un d'aigri, si on est quelqu'un en colère
si on est quelqu'un qui raconte du mal sur les autres ou si on est juste content.
On ne va pas forcément utiliser le mot heureux, mais content.
N'hésitez pas à utiliser ces astuces régulièrement.
Au début ce ne sera pas automatique, mais à la fin ça le deviendra.
On prend soin aujourd’hui de notre corps.
C'est quelque chose que l'on sait, qu'on met en avant. Il y a même des messages sous les pubs, etc.
Mais il faut aussi prendre soin de son mental, l'un va pas sans l'autre.
C'est d'une importance capitale, vous le savez si vous suivez la chaîne
eh bien faites-le, vous avez vraiment tout à y gagner !
Merci encore une fois à Petit Bambou d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas que vous avez le lien dans la description pour la télécharger directement.
Vous avez donc les 8 premières méditations guidées qui sont gratuites
n'hésitez pas en profiter pour l'essayer. Essayez de méditer ! Au moins une fois,  10 minutes !
N'oubliez pas également de laisser un like si cette vidéo vous a plu
de me suivre sur Instagram pour suivre les Fun Facts et les jeux.
Ici vous avez une vidéo de la semaine dernière, la dernière qui est sortie
et ici c'est une vidéo concept interactive - jeu - escape game que j'avais faite pour le million d'abonnés, très cool aussi.
À très bientôt ! Ciao !
Et Loïc ! Je crois que cette blague n'a jamais été faite encore...